kobo regarde mais c'est les pertes que
saab
c'est peut-être un piège vous permettez
pourquoi si c'est toi qui vas c'est
moins piège furtif et mon deuxième
prénom
oubliez le premier mais tu te souviens
du deuxième ne vous inquiétez pas je
m'en charge
legrand scame héros de la victoire
finalement je monte charge
tu es plus fort de jour en jour il n'a
peut-être pas de quoi se réjouir autant
parce que plus on est fort plus le monde
est dangereux
la vie se débrouille toujours pour
équilibrer les choses est-ce que ça
t'arrive de dire des trucs encourageant
je t'encourage à ne pas mourir
il fait on court et je n'ai pas mourir